[Musique]
à l'époque où je faisais bas minuit sur
l'a5 de berlusconi un jour je suis congo
quarantaine 2 par la direction d'antenne
2 et ils me disent on voudrait remplacer
les enfants du rock le samedi soir les
enfants du rock ses missions de rock
qu'elle beaucoup de succès qui passaient
tous les samedis soirs et qu'est ce que
vous feriez si on vous donnait le samedi
soir j moi je ne ferais pas une émission
de rock
je ferai une émission rock c'est à dire
que je parlerai de tout sur un ton rock
et pas seulement du rock and roll sont
ni ouais c'est pas mal ça leur plaisait
il mendie le titre comble appelleriez
cette émission et là je me suis souvenu
d'un titre que j'avais fait pour la
marque
essilor la marque de lunettes essilor
parce que je travaillais dans un
magazine qui s'appelait façade magazines
branchés aux halles et les annonceurs
nous demandait de faire des annonces de
pub en fonction du journal qui ne soient
pas les mêmes que celles qu'ils
utilisaient dans la presse ont en
général et donc j'avais trouvé lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches et là d'un
seul coup je dire à la direction de
l'antenne de gibbons d'appeler sa
lunette toit pour nuits blanches
mackerer formidable formidable voilà
donc ils m'ont dit d'accord et là je
pars à new york
j'avais pas le générique et en baladant
dans la rue joue un abri bus avec un
milk shake des lunettes noires lui c'est
ça l'idée on va prendre que des stars
mondiales avec des lunettes noires
et puis pour la musique comme à l'époque
j'étais dans bowie à berlin j'ai pris
nightclubbing par iggy pop qui
correspondaient effectivement très bien
ce que je voulais raconter alors
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche c'est
très différent de bain de minuit c'est
un bain de minuit maîtrisé c'est un peu
la différence qui entre la haute couture
et le prêt-à-porter c'est à dire que là
pour la première fois je commence à
organiser les émissions l'industrialiser
les tournages c'est à dire que quand il
avait deux stars américaines à paris on
les tourne et toutes les deux mois on
les garde et donc on avait un stock
d'interviews et chaque semaine on a
semblé en fonction de notre grille de
programmation ce qui devait les
émissions assez homogène une étoile pour
lui blanche
c'est la naissance des interviews
formaté parce que avant moi dirais-je
seule interview formaté qui avait la
télé c'était le questionnaire de proust
qui était fait par bernard pivot dans
apostrophe n'y avait pas d'autres
interviews formaté et là j'ai commencé à
me dire il ya plein de façons de faire
des interviews une des premières que
j'ai fait c'est l'anti portrait chinois
alors le portrait chinois ces sites
étaient une fleur quelles fleurs serais
tu sauf que moi gentil portrait chinois
c'est si tu étais un bouton si c'était
une cicatrice s'il était une trahison
alors ça marche est très très bien avec
les écrivains mais évidemment il trouvé
ça formidable d'être un bouton une
cicatrice faut se donner des trucs très
très bon ensuite y avait des questions
qu'ont les questions qu'on y avait
surtout l'histoire du vaisseau spatial
tu dois partir dans un vaisseau spatial
en trois ans alors là il y avait une
liste de noms absolument épouvantable et
les jambes elle s'était bien obligé d'en
choisir un ce a donné lieu à évidemment
à des scènes très marrante iv le who's
who are le who's who c'est un tir aux
pigeons
car je balançais des noms de gens connus
il suffisait de les flinguer comme un
pigeon d'argile quoi il ya eu
l'interview première fois l'interview
alerte aux roses
enfin voila c'est là que j'ai créé
toutes ses interviews là jusqu'au jour
où je me suis aperçu que j'utilisais
toujours les mêmes et j'ai décidé de
faire des interviews à domine m
c'est à dire des interviews aux
fonctions de l'invité par exemple
françoise hardy l'interdît termes là
qu'il de damart est ce que comme tous
les garçons et les filles de ton âge ta
les gens me gonfle le soir ou de george
foreman l'interview suicide je disais
que c'était pas c'est un mauvais boxeur
et à chaque fois il se lever pour me
casser la gueule
donc là on a commencé à sophistiquer le
truc mais c'était après chaque semaine
dans lunettes noires et ça en dit long
sur la télévision d'aujourd'hui
il y avait une interview pinceau c'est à
dire qu'on a reçu toutes les stars de la
peinture à commencer par keith haring on
a reçu même jour paix qu'on a reçues
berlin venait on a reçu des tas de
peintres y en avait un par semaine vers
minuit le samedi soir sur antenne 2 dans
l'émission a été tournée au palace et au
sous sol du palace dont le restaurant
qui s'appelait le privilège et un jour
le directeur de production m'appelle et
me dit thierry le pain c'est fermé une
histoire de drogue
on a tout essayé on ne pourra pas
tourner l'émission aujourd'hui
là il a fallu improviser un lieu de
tournage à côté dans un cas
fait à côté ça c'était vraiment
incroyable et puis après on est allé
dans une toute petite boîte qui
s'appelait le qui n'existe plus qui
s'appelait le shéhérazade une boîte
minuscule très chic qui faisait 40
mètres carrés et on a tourné la fin de
saison
dans cet endroit dans lunettes noires
j'ai envie de vous recommander la
spéciale gainsbourg en fait son staff
m'appelle le dit thierry sièges
devraient absolument faire une émission
avec toi alors c'est très bizarre parce
qu'en général c'est plutôt nous qui
demandons que les stark qui demandent
surtout serge gainsbourg je comprends
pas pourquoi il veut faire cette
émission avec moi on l'a fait une
après-midi d'ailleurs pas le soir une
après-midi et c'était incroyable parce
qu'il y avait tout le monde voulait
rencontrer gainsbourg j'ai fait venir
antoine blondin un grand écrivain qui
avait traîné dans les bistrots de la
rive gauche pendant des années ils
voulaient rencontré béatrice dalle
ensuite il y avait tout le monde qui
était dans cette émission ils sont
incroyables et quand on a fini de
tourner je vais voir l'attaché de presse
et jeudi m'enfin c'est bizarre comme
pourquoi serge a voulu absolument faire
cette émission et là il me dit il rentre
à l'hosto demain il a une chance sur
deux dit rester et il voulait faire sa
dernière émission une émission
testamentaire avec toi dans lunettes
noires je me souviens de yoko ono je
vous conseille de le regarder yoko ono
j'ai pu lui dire en face
enfin le mal qu'elle avait fait à
l'adolescent que j'étais quand elle a
provoqué la séparation des beatles et je
crois que ce jour là j'ai venger toute
une génération
il ya eu crime si jones aussi qui nous
parlait du rap et le rap la remplacer le
rock
nous on se met à peine ce que c'était le
rap à bon oui vous allez voir ils
avaient raison et aussi el mout bergen
elle me berg avec une interview en
français mais il était tellement défoncé
c'est quoi la seule fois que c'est
arrivé il a fallu sous-titré l'interview
en français pour que les gens
comprennent ce qu'ils racontaient les
corrections de ne rien rater
vinardi tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu